[Music]
on this Wednesday night dismantling an
encampment that's taken over at downtown
Street City of Vancouver Crews and
police move in to clear the sidewalks
every day we're hearing new and
sometimes horrific stories what this
could mean for the people who were in
there
the outrage and the risk of violence
could spread
on the way home questions about the
Canadian women with suspected ties to
Isis being repatriated
thank you global national with Donna
Friesen good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin in Vancouver where
dozens of police officers have been
deployed to help clear an encampment in
the city's downtown east side
[Applause]
Street City Crews support
s morning the city of Vancouver says
there's been a steady deterioration in
public safety and an increase in fires
in the area police estimate there are 85
shelters some housing multiple people
the city says it will work with them to
find alternative housing but homeless
Advocates call today's sweep cruel and
inhumane Grace key is at the scene Grace
for people who don't know this part of
Vancouver how many blocks of Hastings
are we talking about and how is the
process going
well this main area here is about three
blocks long right now I'd say all the
tents and structures have been removed
the whole process took probably roughly
about five hours today so these tents
have been here since the summer and
since then the city has removed more
than 600 tents and structures and
assisted with more than 90 people with
housing there have been more than 400
fires with four people hurt assaults and
crime have also been on the rise
every day we're hearing new and
sometimes horrific stories theft
vandalism senseless acts of violence
violence against women and more
specifically violence against indigenous
women local businesses have been damaged
resulting in fires and numerous
explosions which make it dangerous for
anybody walking down that street anybody
living in the tents and anybody in the
buildings using police here to solve
home homelessness is not a solution
we're just going to replicate 10 cities
what people need is housing that they
want adequate dignified housing now and
an end to this undignified dehumanizing
process which isn't helping Grace with
you and Cameron's have been there since
last summer why is the city acting now
and how are the people who are being
told to move on reacting
well the city says it's just sort of
escalated to a point because of the
fires and the risk of harm to folks here
the amount of crime and assaults that
take that has been taking place that
they felt that they did need to do
something now as for the folks who are
being asked to move now so far it's been
going on fairly peacefully now
throughout the morning the police have
been moving this line and trying to move
folks over now whenever that happens
there has that has been met with some
resistance but so far I'd say there's
been no major violent incident to report
but certainly obviously the situation
here has been tense throughout the day
all right Grace Key in Vancouver thanks
the family of a man who had his throat
slashed on a Transit bus in Surrey BC on
the weekend is speaking out tonight the
suspect Abdul kawama is charged with
attempted murder and being associated
with the so-called Islamic State the
victim's family says they had no idea
why he was targeted and that he knows
how close he came to dying ether garcha
reports in a warning some of the images
in her story may be disturbing
the victim of an attack on a Transit bus
in Surrey BC Saturday is out of Hospital
four days after the near fatal incident
which investigators are treating as
terrorism it scared him to his core he
thought he was going to die the victim
asked for his identity to be protected
but agreed to show the 10-inch gash on
his neck his brother-in-law told Global
News the knife nicked his vocal cords
and missed his main artery by a
millimeter he does remember fighting the
guide to the door and pushing him out
but all he remembers is struggling
keeping those arms off of him
but most of his memory of what happened
is blurry how many more people on that
bus would have been affected how many
would have been attacked we don't know
the end result of what that guy wanted
to do or why Abdul kawam is alleged to
have slashed his throat on a Transit bus
and assaulting a second victim at a
nearby bus stop kawam faces four
terrorism charges along with attempted
murder prosecutors allege the attacks
were carried out for the so-called Islam
Islamic State he was initially only
charged with attempted murder before
RCMP National Security Police took over
the investigation following what they
describe as several concerning comments
when we found out it was terrorism I
think most of us were just we were numb
like why it marks the first time a
terror charge has been laid in Canada
since the truck attack in which four
members of the afsal family were
murdered in London Ontario a case which
has yet to go to trial we actually had
one of those incidences happen to us
with the population and land mass of
Canada so yeah we were taken off we were
shocked by it none of the allegations
have been proven in court Jensen says
well his brother-in-law's physical scars
May heal in several months the emotional
ones are deep he is not a violent man he
doesn't preach violent Solutions he
wants to see Canadians helping each
other he wants to see Canadians
remembering we're all Canadian we're all
here together but it's through support
of family friends and community that he
says he'll find Hope nitugarcha Global
News Surrey BC
a number of Canadian women and their
children who have been held for years in
detention camps for family members of
suspected Isis militants are on their
way back from Syria to Canada they're
being repatriated after a lengthy legal
battle as turia Israel reports it's
unclear what will happen to them when
they get here
this camp in the Syrian desert houses
women with suspected ties to Isis and
their children some of the detainees are
Canadians and after years in captivity
they're leaving regardless of why or how
they ended up in northeastern Syria they
are still Canadian citizens and they are
entitled to
protection under the Charter of Rights
and Freedoms a court ordered the federal
government to repatriate six mothers and
their 13 children three of those women
used to live in Edmonton while the other
three are from Toronto for some of these
women they will have completely
abandoned the violent ideology some
women will have remained committed to
the ideology a Quebec mother of six
remains in the camp Canada is watching
very very closely and engaged with all
of our responsibilities and not
but for obviously reasons I will not be
commenting any further on this issue the
women were captured during the fall of
Isis and placed in camps run by Kurdish
forces Global News spoke to one of the
Canadian women in 2018 who said her
husband tricked her into going
it's not clear whether she or others
will face terror-related charges once
they arrive in Canada the challenge of
course is then producing or reproducing
that evidence in a Canadian court of law
getting Witnesses here who who might be
able to testify whether the evidence
gathered in another jurisdiction could
and would be admissible in a Canadian
Court three women with alleged ties to
Isis have already returned here but only
one is facing charges I've always
maintained from day one that the
children should have been repatriated
ASAP because the children did not make a
conscious decision to join Islamic State
their parents did the other big question
is what happens to their children the
RCMP will not say whether they will be
taken away by child welfare agencies or
placed with relatives once they arrive
in Canada Donna all right turia Israel
and Ottawa thanks a multi-billion dollar
settlement for children and families in
this country who are harmed by
underfunding on reserve child welfare
services has reached a final step it now
has to be approved by the Canadian Human
Rights tribunal the revised settlement
endorsed by the Assembly of First
Nations is worth 23.3 billion dollars up
three billion dollars from the original
proposal at least forty thousand dollars
will be paid to thousands of eligible
First Nations individuals and families
David Aiken reports on the impact the
long-awaited settlement will have and
what Advocates are still hoping for
my name is Ashley Bach and I'm from the
Michigan First Nation in Northwestern
Ontario anishinaabioski Nation territory
however I didn't get to grow up in my
community because I was apprehended into
foster care at Birth and then adopted
out later on Ashley Bach was one of
thousands of First Nations boys and
girls taken from their families and
placed in one foster home after another
suffering the separation from their
birth families and too often the loss of
their language and their culture now
there's an agreement and compensation of
at least forty thousand dollars per
person we are proud to say that this
revised agreement is the best possible
for our children and families who have
been so significantly impacted by
Canada's discrimination this has been a
really long and emotional process and
for me it feels like almost a sort of
spiritual journey and when I'm doing
this work it feels like I'm in like a
mode that's almost like ceremony it's
still not clear how many will be
eligible for a payment but it will
include tens of thousands of people
placed in 5 foster care since 1991 as
well as any First Nations child on or
off Reserve deprived of essential
services at any time this settlement
will pay more compensation to more
affected individuals
than any other supplement in the history
of Canada but victims also seek one
other thing an official apology from
Canada to be delivered by the Prime
Minister I mean it signifies that Canada
really truly does
recognize and understand those harms
that they perpetuated against us an
official apology would also be an
important signal in the change of
Canadian Consciousness about the plight
of First Nations I think Canadians have
now understood that the federal
government underfunds things like water
and all these other things on reserve
and that is just uh that's just not fair
and people are demanding better the
settlement now goes to the Canadian
Human Rights tribunal and the Federal
Court of Canada for final approval ask
for That official apology well
discussions among all parties continue
Donna all right David in Ottawa thanks
to Jerusalem now where tensions are high
after Israeli police raided the Alexa
mosque one of Islam's holiest sites
during Ramadan prayers Witnesses say the
police stormed in and beat people inside
the mosque arresting hundreds of
Palestinians the mosque is frequently a
Flashpoint and past raids have sparked
wider conflicts Crystal gemancing
Reports on what happened and the
reaction
[Music]
during Ramadan in the third holiest
sight for Muslims Israeli police forces
used batons in the butt end of their
rifles to beat worshipers the police
shared their own video of the raid but
theirs didn't include any images of
worshipers being attacked
a statement was issued saying security
units were forced to enter the mosque
after masked agitators lock themselves
inside with fireworks sticks and stones
and refused to leave I was praying and I
was sitting on a chair reciting the
Quran they hurled stun grenades one of
them hit my chest
the Al-Aqsa mosque is on a Hilltop in
the old city of occupied East Jerusalem
the mosque is on the southern part of
Temple mount the holiest site in Judaism
with the start of Passover Israeli
forces also said they were clearing the
site based on visiting rules to ensure
there weren't hostilities between the
two groups a poor in thin veil for abuse
according to Canadians for justice and
peace in the Middle East it's not just
because of the fact that religious
holidays are happening is because the
context is occupation the context is for
repression following the raid and
arrests of hundreds of worshipers
rockets were fired from Hamas controlled
territory in the Gaza Strip
most were reflected by Israel's Iron
Dome and then fire returned the U.S
Jordan Turkey and Canada have all
condemned the violence against
worshipers we need to see Israel the
Israeli government shifting in its
approach and Canada is saying that as a
deer and close and steadfast friend to
Israel Canadians for justice and peace
in the Middle East want to see actions
such as an arms embargo with Israel
something the NDP leader called for back
in 2021 when a nearly identical chain of
events led to a bloody 11-day war given
Israel's far-right government there are
fears the Flames of conflict are only
just beginning to be stoked Crystal the
mansing global news London
spring storms and weather warnings
coming up the messy mix of weather
affecting millions of Canadians
it is spring in Canada but you'd hardly
know it in some places over half a
million customers are without power in
parts of Ontario and Quebec because of
an ice storm a messy mix of freezing
rain thunderstorms and strong winds of
pummeled parts of the region some
amazing shots of the fierce lightning
strikes in Southern Ontario weather
warnings are in place well into tonight
and in southern Manitoba and Northern
Ontario people are grappling with a
spring snowstorm that shut down a number
of Highways led to dozens of school
closures some parts of the region are
expected to get as much as 30
centimeters of snow
in the United States multiple deaths are
reported after a tornado tore through
Southeastern Missouri overnight
the power went off and the house just
started shaking so we were very
fortunate our shop is leveled our barn
is leveled our Chicken Shack is level
but our house is here
Drone footage shows how widespread the
damage is in Glen Allen a town about two
hours south of St Louis State officials
have confirmed at least five deaths so
far but say that number could rise as
search and rescue efforts are still
underway millions in the region remain
under some kind of tornado watch as the
bad weather is expected to continue into
tonight
[Music]
presidential prosecution ahead how
Donald Trump is campaigning on the
criminal charges against him
former U.S president Donald Trump has
lashed out at the New York City judge
who arraigned him on 34 counts of
business fraud no one is surprised he's
fighting back even fundraising on the
criminal charges laid against him he's
counting on it helping him win the
presidency again as Jackson prosco
reports
back on home turf at Mar-A-Lago Donald
Trump was defiant there is no case
there's no case previewing how his legal
troubles will feed a campaign of
personal grievance this fake case was
brought only to interfere with the
upcoming 2024 election President Trump
the rally came after Trump's day in a
New York Court where he sat silently as
he was charged with 34 counts of
business fraud the presiding judge
warned Trump against making public
statements that could incite violence
against anyone involved in the case
by Tuesday night the presidential
candidate had found a new message for
his campaign I have a trump-hating judge
with the trump-hating wife and family
the criminal is the district attorney so
far the indictment has only helped
Trump's campaign he has fundraised
millions by playing the victim and is
even selling a fake mug shot his
popularity among Republicans has soared
as he fights for his party's nomination
controversy is often Trump's best weapon
Trump benefits in the short term a great
deal from all the attention he will sort
of push all of the other contenders out
of the media sphere and soak up all of
the oxygen the legal troubles are now so
inescapable that Trump has no choice but
to intertwine them with his presidential
campaign his next court appearance here
in New York is just weeks before the
Iowa caucuses between now and then he
faces the serious risk of additional
prosecution in multiple other
investigations
what helps them with Republicans could
hurt him in the 2024 election making him
a risky and damaged name on the ballot
it simply reinforces particularly among
independent voters that he comes with
liabilities Trump likely wouldn't have
it any other way as a twice impeached
and defeated former president he hopes
claims of political persecution can give
him new political life
Jackson prosco Global News New York